if there is one franchise of movies that
have given us so much joy so much
blessing who's always been there no
matter what other franchises might come
in Twilight black panther might come in
oh you can mean empty prequels memes
have always been there and will always
be there as well the Star Wars prequel
memes is the most powerful meme
franchise of all time and if you think
otherwise then I Got News for you you're
a dummy dum dum bum
[Music]
sequel's has the kind of room the room
status were like literally any line from
the damn prequels can be a meme itself
you just say that one line and you'll be
like oh where have I heard that oh yeah
from the prequels oh that's a meme
nevertheless meme right always to have a
lot of fun setting each other prequel
meme so now you can go join in on the
joke and it will be ruined for everyone
as always that's right my admission is
to destroy old memes when your Padawan
starts dealing in absolutes betrays the
Republic and slaughter a bunch of
children I hate it when he does that
it's when you realize that prequel means
we're probably originally originally
created to mock the cheesiness and
stupidity of the prequels and now
everyone including yourself loves the
prequel even more big I need to rewatch
their prequels it's been too long
dad why was my sister named peace dad
your mom always thought the world needs
peace thanks dad no problem obi-wan
standalone movie stirring everything
record is not a bad name honestly I
would be proud to carry that name we
love what you're doing to help but no
matter the intent our policy is not to
run ads on videos about tragedies the
tragedy of dark plague is the Y's HD
Star Wars Episode three Revenge of this
set Wow hypocrisy enough for you YouTube
every time I've seen this too many times
I can't believe they actually lit Hayden
Christensen on fire and kill him just
for this scene such dedication on his
part that's right he died after this you
ever seen Christian Hayden in any other
movie after the prequels complete did
not just kill his career he actually
died that's the reason why he was so
dedicated to this what would you choose
$1,000,000 or Evan McGregor unexpectedly
jump down behind you missed some point
in life
and says hello there I think the choice
is obvious
I would definitely spend on Aven
McGregor I would spend you know I spent
my entire YouTube fortune on ever
McGregor just as many times as possible
hello that Columbine Virginia Tech
Tucson Aurora Fort Hood white her I want
a divorce I'm so sick and tired of you
quoting Star Wars it's reason that
crimson wrong it's treason to any line
from the prequel is a mean it's treason
[Music]
it's treason then
it's treason he jumps back up I thought
I saw that one can we I told you can we
literally can we use literally anywhere
from person possibly prequel fans when
you make fun of the prequels sequel fans
when do you make fun of this the means
just made it worse it ruined one of the
greatest franchises of all time but the
memes balanced out its the most powerful
source of life it's the most powerful
currency when your own prequel memes for
three hours and there's no perhaps the
archives are incomplete means impossible
perhaps the archives are incomplete glad
we have that line out of the way now
let's go to all of the other ones George
Lucas when the prequel finish I guess
you guys aren't ready for that yet but
your kids are gonna love it it's so true
well I actually like the prequels as a
child at least the first one I'll admit
it but now I just enjoy it for the
pleasure when you can no longer watch
the prequels properly because every
scene became he what have I done how do
you how would you watch it properly
anyway when you take your mates phone
and you check his browser history but
you can't find any porn impossible
perhaps the archives are incomplete
perhaps literally just a picture of
Anakin Skywalker made out of pictures of
sand man he sure looks irritated by that
fact doesn't he I don't like sand its
course
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere
the romance in the prequel is one of the
finest things ever ever written and
acted it you feel the emotion in each
single line I don't like sand I don't
like sand you've heard of been small now
get ready for a quiet gone
Jim hot damn that strong that's a lot of
muscle when the most up voted posts own
sequel memes is now the Senate I love
democracy don't we all just love
democracy I love them obviously if this
post somehow gets 130 1072 up votes I'll
post it again with two hundred and sixty
two thousand one hundred and seventy
seven Evans guys if there's one good
thing that we can do out of this video
is to upload this post it's the number
two most up voted post we need to get
this to one hundred and thirty thousand
so we can get to see more Evans we need
ever McGregor to act in the new Star
Wars movie we can't have some fake-ass
cheap-ass actor playing playing obi-wan
Kenobi he's the one and only except
maybe me I feel like I could do it but I
have this feeling that Disney doesn't
really like me that much I just care
dude you've been getting those vibes so
I should probably step aside for this
one
your thoughts dwell on your mother my
thoughts dwell on your mother
oh damn George Lucas really had some
savage lines in there man
some really good writing when you
realize that senator is an anagram for
treason
that George Lucas was a genius and
underrated mind if this gets 10,000 up
votes I'll have this image tattooed on
my chest where is it where's the proof
top three actors that could totally play
over one Kenobi in a Star Wars spin-off
movie I don't know if you guys seen any
interviews with ever McGregor talking
about the Star Wars he's like the only
actor I've seen that talks about the
prequels in a way that's loving and
endearing everyone else is just talking
about him like oh god let's just pretend
that never happened what would you do
for love I saw this in a commercial
today not the younglings Anakin not the
young Lynx it's over mannequin I have
the high ground beautiful
bravo Bravo we've done it we peaked you
heard about qui-gon gym now get ready
for a chant canceller hell protein hot
damn
god damn you may not like it but this is
what peak performers look like cowgirls
see hi
six-inch 5 foot 11 this is so true mykes
I keep ridiculing me for this exact same
thing rights record freeze-frame yeah
that's me and you're probably wondering
how I got into this situation that's
good why don't we not have any do it
means there has to be oh my god
but can you do it but can you do it the
high ground but can you do okay I think
that's enough
pretty cool face the sukkah merch is
only available for a few more days guys
please you don't want to miss on this
one this is the finest merch of all time
check it out link in the description
before it goes away forever that's it
for me for now we leave like muted or
watching and as always goodbye a
comrades oh and also did I tell you ash
is coming out for all consoles ever
check out a link in description enjoy
have fun